le mystère demeure entier après la
disparition depuis mercredi soir d' une
estivante de 23 ans sophie arnould dans
la région de cabo yven au près d'ajaccio
sophie arnould originaire du pays de
montbéliard disparaît subitement le 4
septembre 1985 en plein maquis corse
les recherches resteront vaines les
pistes sans issue pour ses parents
josette et jacques un long combat
commence au départ d'abord on ne sait
pas donc on pense qu'on va la retrouver
ça c'est sûr si vous voulez on a
toujours l'espoir de la retrouver le
plus dur a été après les jours passent
et jour pas à ses pires ne retrouve pas
sophie et puis voilà ça c'est cet après
sophie n'est pas la seule à manquer à sa
famille
chaque année en france 50 mille
personnes disparaissent seuls dix mille
d'entre elles sont inscrites sur le
fichier des personnes recherchées pour
les mineurs ou les majeurs placés sous
protection
la justice ouvre systématiquement une
enquête et diligente des recherches mais
pour les majeurs la disparition doit
être jugée inquiétante risques de
suicides d'accidents dans les hypothèses
criminels comme pour sophie arnould ou
plus récemment narumi kurosaki la jeune
étudiante japonaise à besançon la
justice va plus loin
lorsqu'on est effectivement dans les cas
de figure de personnes jeunes même deux
majeurs qui d'un moment à l'autre
disparaître en laissant tout chez eux
enfin voilà s'évapore j'allais dire là
on peut retrouver avec des proches très
inquiet là on peut effectivement on peut
effectivement ouvrir ensuite une
information judiciaire pour que les
investigations se poursuivent sur un
plus long terme quand l'enquète
s'essouffle les parents ne désarment pas
pendant plusieurs années josette et
jacques sont retournés en corse
ils ont tout tenté sollicité des médiums
des voyants et comme beaucoup ils ont
engagé un détective privé
c'est vrai que si on découvre des
éléments intéressants ou important d'une
piste quelconque qui viendraient
justifier une disparition inquiétante
peut-être un meurtre d'enlèvement ou
autre et bien bien évidemment ça va être
après les services énergétiques qui vont
prendre le relais souhaite la justice
qui va s'en saisir
toutes ces démarches ont un coût pour
ces familles en souffrance pour les
soutenir les arts nous lançons 1989
l'association disparition espoir pendant
16 ans ils vont se battre pour leurs
enfants et ceux des autres une lutte
parfois sans fin je dirais que d'un cas
des disparitions inquiétantes la
majorité des affaires ne sont pas
résolues on ne retrouve pas les
personnes c'est toujours terrible quand
vous avez des enfants qui n'avaient
aucune raison de disparaître
on ne retrouve ni les corps pour les
familles c'est terrible pour parce
qu'elles ne peuvent pas faire le deuil
et puis parce que nous on est là
effectivement pour pour les aider à cela
en tout cas pour savoir ce qui s'est
passé pour leur expliquer ce qui a pu se
passer et on est toujours extrêmement
frustré évidemment lorsque ce type
d'enquêté n'aboutit pas
ça ça pèse quand même sur vos épaules
parce que c'est vrai que tous les jours
sauf ices et on se réveille la nuit
qu'est ce qu'elle fait est ce qu'elle
est décédée c'est ça c'est le fait de ne
pas savoir
on me dira elle est décédée c'est
terrible à dire je me dirai enfin voilà
trente deux ans après la douleur est un
peu plus discrète
l'espoir demeure mais josette et jacques
ont laissé la vie reprendre le dessus
je sais peux même pas vous dire comment
tiens le coup c'est comme ça je pense
que entre nous il ya beaucoup de
compréhension et de l'amour
et puis l'amour de nos enfants